and i think truth overall in these
marketplaces does out compete fiction
the problem is that power also it
competes weakness right and so we have
these ideas that are basically
empowering or self-empowering that
basically um sort of you know like
dominate these markets and become
basically there's totally unaccountable
and there's no power that can remove
them so for example you know one of the
things that so for example just for the
experts right yeah these experts
counsel on foreign relations are those
the experts those are definitely the
experts international monetary fund are
those the experts sure but here's
another example here's another example
basically
um you know peter dazzak and his friends
yes yes you may have covered that yeah
well i've we haven't covered it but i
know what you're talking about yeah you
know what i'm talking about so the best
place to read about peter dazak and his
his friends is in all places one of my
favorite magazines
um it's called um vanity fair and for
some reason vanity fair has done some
very good articles lately yes i'm not
sure what happened there maybe they took
so acid i don't know we'll get to the
acid soon um um but they did two really
excellent articles
about the birth of kovid that we're not
you know basically beholden to the
virology industry and i think that
basically probably the previous industry
that it has done as much damage as the
virology industry to human health is
probably the tobacco industry right and
so basically when
you sort of look at what happened in
envirology it's sort of as good a case
against the american system as chernobyl
is against the russian system right the
difference is it killed about a thousand
times as many people right um
maybe ten thousand right a lot more and
and and you know essentially what
happened here
is you know there's a funniest way to
tell the story about covid which is a
kid remember i grew up and you were one
of the first people yeah on the internet
to say this is going to be a problem yes
yes i was saying i was i was i started
writing a piece in the middle of january
i actually started investing in covet i
bought like deep out of the money puts
wow it was insane to be betting on kovid
because you can't become like pro
coveted you start talking your book that
was really weird yeah that really biased
my coverage but yeah um um i'll admit
that yeah and and that's sort of in a
way that's the same effect as the effect
that corrupts these these systems so
what happened in the case of here's my
narrative of kovid so when i was a kid i
was in the commonwealth world and like
cyprus and it was very easy to get like
british books one very common form of
british books were these books by gerald
durrell brother of lawrence
uh hbo where someone had the you know
the durells and corfu had this beautiful
you know why not show that was basically
made out of his wonderful memoirs
absolutely great to read when i was 12.
and darrell was a zoologist and he went
around collecting little fluffy animals
from like
imperiled commonwealth countries in
which you know barbarians were about at
the gates right it was just the crazy
times like the 50s and 60s
everything is falling apart right and
he's collecting beautiful fluffy animals
for his little zoo back in england and
he does well with us and he does well
with his books he found the zoo in
jersey uh not new jersey but jersey and
um
he basically um you know creates this
organization called the wildlife trust
which is dedicated to
you know getting rich old ladies to give
money to go and collect little fluffy
animals sounds like a win
um along comes this guy peter dazzak who
has some like [ __ ] degree from
somewhere but is really a science
administrator and he decides and he
becomes the administrator of the
wildlife trust and he decides that he
can start getting grants bigger grants
better grants by changing the mission of
the wildlife trust slightly to have it
go around instead of collect little
fluffy animals
collect viruses specifically bat
coronaviruses
so he turns the wildlife trust into
something called echo health alliance
if you've heard um the name
which is an organization that basically
kind of gets massive grants and
redistributes them to scientists to
basically find and study bat
coronaviruses
um
and some of this work is done in china
this is not really a thing about chinese
science maybe it's something about how
like sloppy things are in china but like
there's a word um for like i'm going to
butcher this
this is uh what uh chinese word you were
saying
it means no you did it okay
i speak mandarin oh awesome awesome my
daughter speaks mandarin
i was like i was like wow you just fixed
that yeah
fluid mandarin awesome awesome awesome
awesome so so basically so this research
into bat coronaviruses is sub cracked
subcontracted uh you know which is to
like
biosafety level two you know research
for seeing like the boondocks of china
right you know
[ __ ] han
right right you know it's not shanghai
right you know and and it's like what
would be the american equivalent of
wuhan um detroit detroit right okay we
heard that you they were doing the most
important or any kind of important virus
research in detroit we would be we would
be asking more questions right right
right right so this research is
basically subcontracted to detroit now
two things about this research one is
its justification is to quote predict
the emergence of you know novel
coronaviruses the cause of this research
was the original outbreak of sars
right and in fact one of the people
involved in like virology governance is
a technical advisor to the stephen
soderbergh film contagion which is well
worth watching um which is a uh from the
mid oughts i think yes which is um
basically explicitly about a back
coronavirus yes so because this happened
basically back coronaviruses are a
problem
and because it's a problem yeah so we're
getting we're we're popping the stack
now so so getting back to
this problem so okay back corona viruses
are a problem therefore they're
important therefore you can get grants
to study them you don't have to rely on
little old ladies anymore instead of
collecting animals you're collecting bad
viruses which means you collect bats so
basically the same thing right right
you're getting all these grants to study
back coronaviruses the more important
um your work is the more money it will
get makes sense we allocate money by
importance yes right the more dangerous
bat coronaviruses are the more money you
will get now back coronaviruses are bad
viruses to operate in humans they have
to mutate
they have to be changed they have to be
mutated either naturally through past or
they have or artificially we had a lab
in the lab and we know that was going on
and we know that basically in the course
of like four days the like head
virologists of the world changed their
minds which they'd come into like this
looks like a lab leak too this doesn't
look like a lab like right there will
never be any accountability for these
[ __ ] and and there's no power
that's going to say hey science you're
[ __ ] and the way in which science is
[ __ ] is like this is a good example
case because basically here is this
problem
of like bat coronaviruses it's a real
problem
no one disputes that
it stars really emerged from animals it
was not a weird soviet experiment that
escaped right so it is possible for this
to be a threat because it is possible
for it to be a threat is a problem
therefore one can get grants to study
this the worse a problem it seems to be
the more grants you're gonna get so you
have basically a feedback loop in the
marketplace of ideas in which this idea
basically brings power to that market
right so if you're basically a bat
coronavirus researcher and you're like
you know what what are we going to do if
we predict an outbreak
right like predicting i predict there
will be an earthquake in the bay area
okay let's build our houses a little bit
stronger right you know what have you
actually done here like uh was any of
this research useful in solving the
actual outbreak absolutely the profit
motive in the marketplace of ideas can
corrupt right but it's not specifically
it's sort of when you think of a profit
motive that's not really the way
academics think they think of like an
empire building motive they think of
like my career is more successful if
this is a bigger problem yes you know
and so they basically play pokemon with
coronaviruses and then they like mutate
their [ __ ] pokemon to make them as
dangerous as possible in like basically
low rent walmart tier
labs in detroit right and then they're
basically like and you know when you
step back the important thing is when
you when you pull the camera back
and you look at this behavior
okay this is absolutely kind of been
blaming china for this no but
we're letting china off and we are a fan
of china on this show and we believe in
one china we don't even know what taiwan
is
so incredibly based yeah incredibly
basic but this isn't a china problem
this is a us problem this is a problem
with with the way we do [ __ ] and we
basically said we're going to take the
experts you know who's going to watch
the watchdogs ancient political question
right and they're like well why don't
the experts watch the watchdogs
excellent answer and then the question
is who watches the experts and they're
like well you know i guess they could
watch themselves right right and when
they watch themselves they do [ __ ] like
this which is every bit as dumb as like
what it was done in [ __ ] chernobyl
where they're like let's turn off the
backup backup backup safety systems
prove that our reactor is safer
for safety systems that breakdown of
covert was the best i've ever heard
thank you i have never heard it anywhere
else thank you and will i hear it
anywhere else who the [ __ ] knows
and that's the problem
because by the way you just did yeah in
a few minutes
in in the most succinct way i've ever
heard and i read and listen to stuff all
the time you literally broke down
not only the problem but what incubates
the problem and why the problem won't go
away yeah yeah yeah okay in fact these
[ __ ] are getting even more
funding that's like because their [ __ ]
is important like funding is going to be
i mean because
it's off the [ __ ] shots you know
i mean the things they're going to be
making now yeah yeah no no and just you
know there's more research for i mean
everything involved in this right and so
inevitably there's a little skepticism
around gain of function you know it's
like you don't want to call it that you
know but this is everywhere you know
it's like i have a you know friend who
um is um i'm gonna disguise his identity
he's a leading figure
in a film in a field that is related to
physics okay and it's related enough
that he knows physics quite well and i
was talking about
um him talking about this problem with
him
and um
he was like um oh yeah you know
why you know in physics it's so bad
that there are entire workshops about
string theory
that aren't about string theory they
just have to actually pretend to be
about string theory because the string
theorists are in command of the funding
because physics is funded by physics so
the thing is when that starts to happen
in like
the us occupation of afghanistan right
right you're basically just like the
idiots are in charge and doing idiotic
things and there is no accountability
for them anywhere in any possible way
shape or form right so let's get back to
the acid so um i i think [ __ ]
deserve a break after that yes um anyway
so you're digesting it because that i
mean that by the way
and not even to just be you know overly
complimentary but like
it's amazing that that that not only has
that not been talked about more um
broadly right but it hasn't been
put in a context that people can
understand well and and not only
understand
that that this is a huge problem but
that
it is it is by design and the design
continue itself perpetuates yes yeah
yeah thank you thank you well thank you
this is poverty this is everything right
yeah right this is poverty this is
homelessness i was in san francisco
there are guys with like devil horns on
all fours
you weren't door street you weren't a
doorstep i know where was i was in there
eating a quesadilla and the mission and
i'm watching all this stuff go on and i
love that city but it has problems it
has issues and i'm going and i'm looking
i live there for 20 years and i'm
looking at these
compassion centers homeless centers
navigation systems navigate their
navigation and no one's in them and no
one cares no it's insane and it has
nothing to do with anything and it's run
by the homeless industrial complex
that's right you know like and like the
chief executive i'm not giving too much
away but like the chief like expert of
the san francisco homeless complex yeah
was actually my girlfriend 20 years ago
oh my god
oh my gosh
you did it
yeah right so so you know and that
really informed me a lot about this kind
of mentality right yeah